[Music]
[Applause]
uh Lewis rck college football analyst
NFL analyst and uh former NFL player
teammate of Dion Sanders back in the
early 9s so he'll be on the call
Colorado Colorado state with Mark Jones
that'll be on the mother ship at 10 p.m.
Eastern on Saturday night he joins us
from Boulder Colorado how is morale in
old er
Colorado Dan it couldn't be higher man I
mean people around here are absolutely
fired up right now as far
as what they've consider to be a new age
in Colorado football I mean it is these
kids here believe in what Dion is doing
in just the way that I expected him to
to be quite honest with you because the
same thing happened in Jackson State
this this is a guy who brings a
tremendous amount of credibility and
competency and they're seeing that he
positively is impacting them on and off
the field from there everything else is
really characterized by 100% buyin man
and the and the fan base around here is
just they're they're excited to see what
this means as far as the upside once
this roster continues to develop and
he's able to get even better big man
because right now from a skill position
perspective you'll see on Saturday night
and you've seen already these guys can
go man they can deal with anybody in the
country from a skill position persp
yeah I thought that they were topheavy
going into this year just because Dion
trying to get his plan in place and
bringing in recruits and get rid of the
old players I thought next year was
going to be that year where you go boy
they made that leap I mean they're so
far ahead uh of expectation level but
also is there any chance they can lose
this game Saturday
night there's always a chance it's a
rivalry game in Colorado state did not
put even close to
their best foot forward against
Washington state two weeks ago when they
went um when Washington State went into
their home place and pretty much took
them apart and Washington State's going
to be a good football team you're going
to see that by the end of this year that
is a darn good football team and they're
going to beat a lot of people yeah
there's always a chance because they can
throw the football too they have a
version of the air raid and they just
made a change at the quarterback
position they've got some wide receivers
that can go also and right now
Colorado's defense it's let's just say a
work in progress all right they're not
they're not going to shut anybody down
they're going to outscore people more so
than they're going to dominate them on
defense but do I expect Colorado to win
this football game yeah I do just I
wonder if Dion can keep these kids
really dialed in and living moment to
moment and not looking ahead because
they've got two just
monstrous tests coming down the road
with Oregon and SC in the subsequent two
weeks so as long as they don't look
ahead and they stay in the moment I
expect them to win the football game but
I don't expect it to be a blowout I hope
it's not a blowout because I hope that
the Rivalry aspect of it and what Jay
norell has obviously sparked around here
in terms of people being fired up I hope
that helps his football team I hope his
team can cash the checks that he's
writing right now for them as far as
what he said uh just
yesterday yeah and you know Dion's
taking whatever it's like the Michael
Jordan method Hey I what what did you
say about me I mean even when guys
didn't say something about Jordan he
still made it into something Dion's made
everything personal opening week it's
personal last week personal now this
became personal because of what the
Colorado State coach had to say what is
Dion's role when the game
starts you know I I think look he he's
obviously put together a very very good
staff I think overall from a 30,000 foot
view perspective there are certain
things in certain ways that he wants
this team to play that he will
definitely communicate to his assistance
as to how he wants the game to unfold I
mean obviously he's a very smart X and0
person both from an offensive and
defensive perspective because he's done
both um but I think he's without a doubt
the CEO and he lets the offensive Co
defensive coaches do what they need to
do and that's that's really the role of
any head coach and he's been very smart
about that from what I can tell I'm
looking forward to like today we're
going to go over to the offices and
we're going to talk with him and I've
texted back and forth with him over the
years and and these are some real good
questions that I'm going to that I'm
wind up asking him just about he how he
runs this operation both from a you know
a preparation standpoint and then a game
T standpoint but I'll tell you this it
looks as smooth as could be and you know
what I I I think the thing that maybe
people will in due time give him more
credit for is the fact that look Dion is
Dion's not just about marketing and hype
this is a football guy man who I I look
I remember back in in the early 90s when
I played with him he is super super
football intelligent now so let's not
just don't let's not get into the to all
the hype and the and the kickoff returns
and interceptions and the way he played
the game this guy's a student of the
game and he's a great leader and he's a
guy who's tremendously Charis
charismatic so people don't want to
believe that people keep like wanting to
like make Digs at this program and say
look this is just a flash in the pen
there's no way they can sustain this
don't bet on that don't bet on that
you'll make yourself look foolish he's
Lewis rck in the mothership he covers
the NFL and college football he'll be on
the call with Mark Jones that'll be
Saturday night at 1000 p.m. Eastern yeah
when you if I would have said at the
beginning of the year when you get your
schedule yep so you knew you were going
to do this game in the preseason no we
did not this is you know you know how
how it goes really in college from week
to week we kind of like um formulate the
schedule as it goes along because you
know obviously with college games you
want to have the
most impactful games in the most
impactful time slot so you know we were
just alerted that we were getting this
game about a week ago and so no there
hasn't been a whole lot towards it the
first two we knew the first couple games
you know the first two weeks of the
season but um no this one was uh we just
found this out about a week ago I I saw
where Mel Kyper said that Dion's son is
now he'll be a first round draft pick
yep okay why wasn't he a first round
draft pick when he was playing at
Jackson State why is it you play two G
like this drives me
crazy he he's the same player and and
was he a first round draft pick at
Jackson State or he just became one
because now he's doing it at Colorado
against TCU and against Nebraska you're
you're you're hitting the nail on the
head Dan I mean look a lot of times what
happens is well first of all you know
what a lot of what Dion wanted to do
down at Jackson State and what he wanted
to do for HBCU overall was get them more
notoriety and get
College scouting Department's scouting
directors general managers taking that
that uh football down there much more
seriously from a NFL perspective and
they weren't that that's just the fact
they weren't and if you throw on the
tape over the past two years of what
shador was able to do down there you
will see many of the same things he's
doing right now I mean he is a guy who
is extremely poised confident smart
strong in the pocket can can create
throw the football at all three levels
can do it all it's just that now he's
doing it on a national stage against
teams that have quote unquote brand
recognition everybody knows everybody
knows TCU everybody knows Nebraska yeah
so now that you're doing it on on Fox
now that you're doing it on
ESPN and people are talking about it
they're kind of like there's there's
more eyeballs on it now people are going
oh okay all right maybe he is pretty
good so look he's been doing this his
whole career and now he's just doing it
on a bigger stage where now people are
going like you know the bandwagon
jumpers are jumping on and I and I don't
want to say that about uh NFL front
offices because they're not necessarily
bandwagon jumpers but I think now you
know a little bit of the herd mentality
does kind of creep in which is well okay
well now it seems like it's okay to
maybe kind of step out there you know go
out on a limb and say yeah this guy is
extremely talented and he is doing it at
a higher level of competition quote
unquote but look he hasn't changed as
far as the characteristics that he has
put on display from day one that he
stepped foot down in Jackson State he's
he's getting better and better but this
young man has always been that player
and if you go back and watch him and you
just change the uniform he looks the
same he's just getting better and he's
doing it on a bigger stage that's all
and Travis Hunter was one of the top
recruits coming out of high school yeah
could you see him playing two-way in the
NFL if someone will let him yeah it's a
really it's not going to be about Travis
not being capable of doing it it's going
to be whether or not people are willing
to let him do it and look I mean there's
been very does Dion see himself and
Travis Hunter no question absolutely no
question yeah and when you break down
his tape Travis right now may be more
skilled and more impactful as a wide
receiver than he even is as a corner
because he I mean just Exquisite route
running ability body control hand eye
coordination attractive football I it's
almost like these guys get bored on just
on defense because they're not at the
point of attack enough I mean they can
be you know eliminated from a game just
by avoiding it wide receiver you can't
eliminate me if they want to get the
ball to me they'll scheme it up to get
it to me and put my hands on Travis is
different he really is and I don't I
don't like you know engaging in
hyperbole too much D but look hav played
with Dion and actually been in awe as a
teammate at how fluid and different and
oneof one he was as a teammate and as a
player when you watch Travis Hunter and
anytime he's at the point of attack if
you were a betting man and you could
absolutely like freeze live action in
that moment in time and go I want to put
some money on whether or not this guy's
going to win this contest yeah you would
bet on this kid every single time and
that's what you would have done with
Dion too I've seen it these guys are
different this young man is different
and when you see Dion talk about Travis
Hunter his eyes get this big because
there's no doubt what he's seeing is
that's a modern day version of me he's
that legit I hope he puts on a show
tomorrow night what's your favorite Dion
Sanders story either on the field or off
the
field I think well I think on the Field
1992 we were playing in
Washington um down at RFK and he hadn't
he hadn't been around because he was
playing baseball at the time and that's
my rookie year really in the NFL and
there was all this Buzz about Dion's
coming tonight Dion's coming today he's
coming he's going to be at the hotel
today he's going to be there he had
taken he hadn't hadn't been part of any
practice any meeting nothing he showed
up on game day they had his uniform laid
out and all this I'm just like I've
never met the guy and my heart's beat
because you know he was he was the dude
at that time and I remember man we were
doing we having our kickoff return
meeting on the sideline because we're
getting ready to go out there and do
kickoff return and I knew he was going
to be back there they were going to put
him back there and he walked into the
Huddle and he said just give me a little
room a little room I'm taking this thing
to the house he said that to a group and
I was just like this guy hasn't even
he's been playing baseball I mean what's
what you what are you talking about and
I'll tell you what Dan they kicked the
ball off man and I was the right the
Left End on the front line of the
kickoff return team I drop back take my
drop you know and I could see the ball
going you know and you hear the crowd
kind of building you know as obviously
the guy catches it and I'm getting my
block and out of the right corner out of
my right eye I just see this blur and I
see these legs kicking
up
oh he froze up and I see him from about
40 oh no wait wait wait hold on you you
froze up started holding that ball with
two hands and then started putting it up
there I was like the first time he
touches
it oh I'm sorry yeah hold on for a
second hold on oh man the best we got
right to the part where a blur went
right by guys yeah okay okay so blur
went by you on the kickoff with
Dion yeah okay so yeah he goes by and I
just see I see him come he's breaking
right up the middle of the formation and
he breaks right to the sideline and he's
about
maybe 40 yard line at this point the
plus 40 yard line and I see he has the
ball in two hands and then he takes it
and you see him put it in one hand and
you just see him start high stepping and
I'm I'm sitting there running and as I'm
running I'm going he told us he was
going to take this thing to the house he
told he hadn't had any practice I had
never met the guy and then he danced for
about 15 seconds 20 seconds in The End
Zone it was just it was the coolest damn
thing man because I was like this guy
literally just flew in the town they put
his uniform out he went back there and
he took it a 100 plus just like that and
I'm going I just looked I was just going
and from that point on I was like look
anything that he wants to do anything he
puts his mind to he's been successful
his whole life let alone what he's
overcome off the field with his health
situation over the past couple years
he's a unique dude man he really is hard
not to be in all of him more impressive
Bo Jackson or Deion Sanders
oh I think because of Bo's
power like B's almost like a myth man
like wasn't even like real you know I
mean how many people right I mean I said
somebody the other day how many people
you know that can take a baseball bat
and crack it over their head and split
it yeah that mean I break my
neck he's Bo B's different and I think
Dion would tell you that too B's just a
different style that that that kind of
power and speed I don't think we've ever
seen that I don't know if we'll ever see
that again I know you were in the uh
Eagles front office um if you were in
the Jets front office right now they
said all right Lewis what are we going
to do with the quarterbacking position
whether it's trading for somebody or as
a starter or bringing in a backup what
would you recommend
I think at this point look you drafted
Zack Wilson number two
overall he's had what five six months
around Aaron Rogers can he play though I
I know you I mean but think about the
alternative you're gonna bring in
somebody new who hasn't been in your
system who hasn't been around your team
and you think you're just going to throw
him into the mix here now in week two
and he's just gonna give you something
that Zach can't just don't really see
that happening either would you want a
veteran presence and influence in your
quarterback room yeah I think he needs
that I think the construct of your of
your quarterback room is is very
important but what what would you be
telling yourself what would you be
saying to
your well I guess you know sometimes you
do have to just face the fact that maybe
you made a mistake the ners did I mean
the Niners admitted they made a mistake
true true you're right you're right and
as I think through it I mean I get your
point but I think for them look
Nathaniel hackets just going to have to
work around whatever deficiencies they
still think Zach
has and they're going to have to make
this work with him and ride the other
strengths of this team as far as they
can go is this going to be what they're
going to have to do because there's
nobody who's just going to ride in and
just kind of save the day and pick up
where Aaron left off this just not going
to happen look this is a tragic case of
a franchise quarterback getting hurt in
a in a in a way that you never could
have foreseen as there is yeah there's
no two ways about that but this is but
this is Zach's moment man from a
physical perspective that isn't the
issue it's all up here we always knew
that about doc bson we're going to see
whether or not Aaron helped him get that
going the right way or not have fun
we'll be watching on Saturday night my
best to Mark Jones uh we play played
played a few basketball games against
each other all right yeah I'll let him
know man thank you man you got it that's
Lewis rck he's also going to be on the
call he's got Monday night Monday night
two games on the mothership Saints
Panthers and then Browns and the
Steelers so you got uh two Monday night
games she'll be doing the Saturday night
game Colorado Colorado State that'll be
at 10: Eastern and uh 10 10 p.m. Eastern
I love it